Vían quan đến vụ biệt kăng được kịch quan công an điều tra về biệt tuần thức phần bệnh và đếp ăn hoặc đường.
Sở giá dụ qua đau táa hanoi với các phần bản người bà nhân dân các phường sẽ ăn vào các đường vị trường học sịch thuật sở.
Tăng kương công tác phản lý và đam ăn toàn thức phần của ăn bán chú trong sinh trên đếp bán thành phố.
Phan bản của sở giá dụ qua đau táo đến liệt bà nhân dân các phường sẽ a kính chà sau mình thung tín nhà thung cốc,
một đau quyền liệu, chuột đau ngạnh báo nguyên cơ, sử liệu xử cố, đều chăng của đau thức phần theo quy định.
Sở giá dụ qua đau táa hanoi của nhiều cơ các chừng miếp kổ kai thức dân, định lợi năng lượng khổ phần,
giang xét nhà thung cốc và một đau thức phần.
Thì phát hiện vì phạm hoặc có giữ hiệu mắt ăn to thức phần, các đơn vị phải mặt con ngay cho chính quyền địa phương.
Cơ quan ý tế và sở giá dụ qua đau táa hanoi để phung hộp sử liệu theo quy định.
Chụt đau cơ quan kẻ xa đau chá con ăn thình của hanoi đã ra quy định khởi tối vụ ăn,
khởi tối tảm bị cân trong đường dây dít mổ, yêu thủ lượng dịch xảy ra tại hanoi.
Tụ đau đau đau ngạnh nghiệm không trong ngày sau đến nay, các đối tượng đã yêu thủ phản hăng
in só chăm con lượng mắt dịch mạnh, tụi đương phản gần bá chăm tấn, số thiết này được đưa và khắc chợp đau mối chợ dân xin,
và bán cho phường tý chách nhiệm của hạn thức phần cường pháp.
Cô tý này đã không có thực phẩm trong một số trình học trên đều bán hanoi.